i have a big announcement that
is a story from kim kardashian's
instagram where she shield
a scam crypto coin to 228
million followers is anyone else sick of
these so-called
influencers right scamming working class
people
their followers and then pretending like
it never happened it continually blows
my mind
that they're allowed to do this and get
away with it but i i want to make this
video as a very clear warning to people
to stay
away from this coin it's called ethereum
max okay promoted by none other than the
hobbit herself
my girl ain't no habit and i know i'm a
fine one to talk here but uh
anyway let's let me tell you all about
it let's go to the board
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
10 million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla
and we've got to take a close look at
this thing because it is
sick what is going on now first of all i
know a lot of you guys are excited
about getting screwed by kim kardashian
but let me tell you
this is not the way okay she posted her
story
saying this guys again real
account i cannot believe we're at this
point right
we used to have the paul brothers
ripping people off with crypto
now we have kim kardashian basically
mrs america herself at this point guys i
have a big announcement
big announcement guys and then it reads
i gotta pause it for a second because
you blink and you'll miss it it says
are you guys into crypto because you
know you know kim
big proponent of crypto always talking
about it and then the first part is our
favorite line on this show
this is not financial advice
it's always this is not financial advice
uh but here let me
let me shill this real quick this thing
i don't believe in and never heard of
prior to five minutes ago
my my publicist told me i could make a
billion dollars she says
but sharing what my friends just told me
about the ethereum max token yeah you
know guys
her friends who also happened to pay her
to do this
because make no mistake this is an ad i
know it's not clear from this wall of
text
a few minutes ago ethereum max burned
400 trillion tokens
that were made up their digital it
doesn't mean anything okay
literally 50 of their admin wallet
giving back to the entire emacs
community
emacs hashtag disrupt this story
ethereum max hashtag wtf
max hashtag g-o-p-max at
ethereum max hashtag ad and then you
have that lovely
swipe up uh just in case you weren't
clear
that this is a paid promotion okay
and this is not for squarespace or
audible
or you know some legitimate product line
it's not even like a makeup
that you you could say kim kardashian
would know something about
this is about cryptocurrencies okay and
specifically
ethereum max is not like a legitimate
cryptocurrency
like ethereum you might be confused you
might think what is that just like
ethereum
no actually ethereum max is trying to
hijack the ethereum name by calling an
ethereum x it has nothing to do with
ethereum
other than it's an erc token like
everything else right now
or i guess there's some bse tokens right
now but you get my point
anyway you go to their page and they
don't have a single white paper on here
instead they're just one of these tokens
that redistributes a little bit of the
money every
time that someone buys their cells by
implementing attacks
which literally every token is doing
right now there's nothing original about
this token
it says it's considered a lifestyle
token it considers itself
the culture token emacs provides access
to vip experiences
it says it has an nft marketplace only
it doesn't exist yet
it's going to be launching uh sometime i
guess this year
it's got a few other buzzwords on here
but here's the main point you need to
know
this post sums everything up 39 minutes
ago
ethereum max had its one month
anniversary
meaning this thing barely exists
the control c control v code base was
just created and kim kardashian couldn't
wait
to get out there and shield these tokens
but why
you might ask yourself i think that's a
really good question like why is it that
all of these influencers are promoting
garbage
scam coins it's an epidemic why
is it peak influence or stupidity well
yes
but there's also a more sinister factor
behind all this right
it's that well with all these new coins
that are popping up
that are just copying other people's
code bases uh or
significantly copying huge parts they
don't add anything to the crypto
community
what they do is rather than spending
money on developers they spend nearly
all their money on marketing budgets
it's all hype right which
means they think their real value
proposition
is like getting enough influencers on
board which let me tell you isn't enough
to launch
a fintech company i'm sorry it's not and
so as a result they have some of the
largest marketing budgets
in the business right now they're paying
enormous unfathomable sums of cash
to get people to promote little 24-hour
stories
and as a result their market cap goes
like this
which they use by the way to sell off
some coins and pay the influencer off
it's a weird scam scheme where like the
influencers really complicit
in this thing like it's pretty clear
that if influencers didn't spend their
time
shilling these coins these scam coins
wouldn't be able to scam
even half as many people and so when i
see stuff
like uh kim kardashian promoting this
garbage i just think to myself you're
hurting your own fans
and you just don't care but she's not
the only one
floyd mayweather you know another person
who knows almost nothing about
cryptocurrencies
was also caught rocking an ethereum max
uh
shirt which again if you just see these
influencers doing that that's the first
sign you run away like if
if gigantic influencers are being paid
to shill it
run away guys i i promise you it's not
worth it but yeah
he also showed this token to his
followers because of course
floyd literally doesn't care about his
fans he cares about the money he's
said as much he literally says they say
it's not all about
the money well your kids can't eat
legacy he was saying this in response to
him scamming his fans
with a bogus boxing match with logan
paul and ethereum max is the same you
could go up to floyd right now and say
hey
you scammed people with ethereum x he
would just tell you like well
yeah i mean my kids can't eat legacy
right but i for one
don't buy this whole like my kids can't
eat legacy thing
because floyd mayweather's kids are not
in danger
of not eating the only thing he's doing
is just squeezing every last
drop of money out of you out of your
soul
um so that he can be more rich and buy
more rolexes and more lambos i mean
let's not pretend this is some
altruistic thing
to feed his family this is i want to be
more rich so screw you i guess this is
really the attitude
of people like this uh who are going
into the crypto space and really
squeezing every last drop of this scam
wave because here's the thing guys
these scam coins won't be around forever
and these influencers know that
and they know they gotta strike while
the iron's hot while it's easy to get
rich
off of your uh failure and you your
accounts blowing up
they know it's a limited opportunity and
they're taking advantage of it so please
guys
be very careful and the last thing i
want to just show you real quick
um is this ethereum max chart i mean
this coin has only been around for a
month and it's
already almost hitting new lows i mean
it is down something like
80 to 90 of its all-time high value
which was right after all this you know
shilling took place
with floyd mayweather and stuff kim
kardashian hilariously has barely showed
up even as a blip
on this thing over here you can see
right here this is when she started to
promote it and it looks like people
actually have been
selling because she bought it which is
hilarious
but honestly i take that for a good sign
i mean seriously when the people who
brought you bound to
are promoting crypto coins it's time to
get out
when you burn uh-huh your plastic stars